mein kollege sascha baumann ist für uns
in ulm sascha du stehst jetzt am rande
des wohngebiets was hat sich da am
wochenende besser gesagt am freitag
abgespielt haben freitag ist hier gegen
21 uhr 5 1 10 15
ein großeinsatz der polizei angelaufen
spezialkräfte der polizei schlichen sich
zum haus von klaus s und rammten die
türe auf überwältigten den rentner in
seinem wohnzimmer
auch seine frau solle kurzfristig in
gewahrsam genommen worden sein
er wurde dann hier hinter mir in der
straße weg gebracht
in handfesseln zu einem streifenwagen
und dann zu einer vernehmung gebracht
sind die ermittler jetzt überhaupt auf
klaus es gekommen
klaus es hat offenbar im internet
verpackungsmaterial bestellt und zwar
das gleiche verpackungsmaterial das bei
den briefbombenanschlägen sichergestellt
werden konnten es war also eher wie
akribische ermittlungsarbeit der polizei
man hat im landeskriminalamt vermutlich
die reste der explodierten sprengsätze
überprüft und kam dann eben auf ein ganz
bestimmtes verpackungsmaterial das
normalerweise nur im gewerblichen
bereich eingesetzt wird das aber klaus
es einige tage vor den taten eben im
internet bestellt haben soll
und so kann man dem rentner dann auf die
spur
wie hoch ist jetzt noch die sorge dass
es weitere pakete oder briefe gibt die
mit sprengstoff zurecht gemacht worden
sind wenn man so sagen möchte und von
klaus es noch vor seiner festnahme
verschickt worden
die sorge war in der vergangenen woche
natürlich berechtigt das war die grosse
sollte anderer lebensmittel hersteller
auch der polizei mittlerweile dürfte
sich die lage etwas normalisiert haben
man weiß es sind nicht mehr wie diese
drei pakete in der postfiliale in ulm
aufgegeben worden man kann es also
nahezu ausschließen dass noch weitere
pakete mit sprengsätzen zu
lebensmittelherstellern unterwegs sind
das sind immerhin gute nachrichten
vielen dank sascha baumann für uns in
ulm wir sind bild und wir liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren